have you ever heard about a company
called oracle
within tech circles oracle is an
industry classic
having been in the business since 1977.
yet for the average person oracle is a
completely
unfamiliar name that's not too
surprising though given that oracle
only has a total of 430 000 customers
worldwide
what's insane though is that oracle is
valued at 240
billion dollars meaning that each oracle
customer translates to over 550 000
worth of market cap to put that into
perspective
facebook has a total of 2.89 billion
active users
and they're valued right at one trillion
dollars this means that each facebook
customer
only translates to 346 worth of market
cap
or nearly 1600 times less so
here's how larry ellison built his 113
billion fortunate
with less than half a million users
worldwide taking a look back
larry ellison was born on august 17th
1944 in new york city
to a single mother his biological father
was a us army air corps pilot
but it doesn't really seem like larry
had much of a relationship with him
in fact he didn't have much of a
relationship with his biological mother
either
when larry was nine months old he caught
pneumonia and his mother would give
larry to her aunt and uncle to raise
these two would basically become larry's
parents as larry wouldn't even see his
biological mother again
until he was 48 years old the uncle
would give larry the last name ellison
as he thought this was a great way to
honor his entry into the u.s
through ellis island as a kid larry was
pretty bright
but it wasn't like he was programming at
the age of 12 or anything
he would end up attending the university
of illinois as a pre-med student
after their first year he was actually
named the science student of the year
but he would never end up finishing his
studies you see
at the end of his second year at college
his adoptive mother would pass away
and larry would miss his final exams i'm
sure he could have arranged to take the
exams
at a different time given the
circumstances but he would decide to
just drop out
altogether soon after he would enroll in
the university of chicago
but larry would drop out of here as well
after the first semester
unlike other tech billionaires he didn't
instantly set out on building a tech
empire
in fact he was pretty lost throughout
his 20s he did hold several respectable
jobs throughout this time period like a
job at wells fargo
however he was constantly switching
around and didn't really have any
purpose
he was able to pick up some computer
programming skills throughout this time
period though
and this would prove extremely valuable
in the 1970s
in 1973 larry was working at an
electronics company called
ampex and this is where he would meet
two men named ed
oates and bob miner by 1976 though
larry would leave ampex as well and join
precision instruments as
vice president but this is when larry
would come across a research paper
written by a british computer scientist
named edgar f codd in the paper cod
described how large amounts of data
could be officially stored using a
relational database model
larry very quickly realized the
commercial potential of such a product
and would reach out to his former
colleagues adults and bob miner about
the idea
the three would get together and start
developing a database solution based on
college research paper
it seems like larry was the most
convinced about the idea though as he
fronted
twelve hundred dollars of the total two
thousand dollars they started with
originally they named the company
software development laboratories
but by the time they finished
development in 1979
they would change the name to relational
software inc in 1979
the trio would launch their database
product which they called oracle to the
public
oracle was the first commercial
sql-based relational database program
on the market but 1979 was simply
way too early for such a product and no
one really cared
so the team had to be extremely
aggressive with their marketing efforts
and even a bit sleazy one example of
this was the naming of the product
itself you see the product wasn't just
called oracle
it was actually called oracle v2 despite
it being the first version
larry ellison figured that people would
be much more likely to buy a second
generation product
so he just went ahead and called the
product v2 despite this though
it was still extremely difficult to make
sales because once again
no one cared at the time fortunately for
the team though
the cia would give them a shot and
become the company's first major
customer
given that the company was only known
for oracle v2
in 1982 the team would decide to change
the name of the company to oracle
systems corporation
over the next couple of years they would
launch newer versions of oracle
and as you would guess each version was
one off version 2 was called oracle v3
version 3 was called oracle v4 and so on
by 1986 oracle started to gain some
serious traction
and they would decide to go public at
ipo each share of oracle was worth 15
which gave the company a valuation of
194 million dollars
so not quite a billion dollar company
but still massive and nonetheless
in 1997 oracle would become the largest
database management company
in the world but this would
unfortunately be the company's last
highlight for
quite some time in 1990 an internal
audit would reveal that oracle had been
overstating their earnings it seemed
like the sales team was counting orders
as sales
and this inflated oracle's top line for
a few quarters oracle would come out
with revised quarterly reports
and they weren't half bad but investors
were not happy
nonetheless looking back you can't even
see this on oracle's talk graph
as it was so insignificant in comparison
to oracle stock price
today but at the time this candle led to
a 75
decline in oracle stock price oracle
also started to face increasing
competition within the database market
as more companies entered the scene as a
result in an effort to diversify and
continue growing
larry would attempt to take oracle into
their personal computer market
he actually had a brilliant idea to
reduce the cost of personal computers
by leveraging databases and networks his
idea was to create something called the
nc
or the network computer this computer
would basically just be a bare-bones
screen
and input device while the actual
computing and processing would be
completed on oracle's networks
he basically wanted to use cloud
computing to reduce the cost of
computers
but as you might have guessed the
technology just wasn't there to create
such a product in the 1990s
moreover the cost of personal computers
were plummeting as technology continued
to advance
so it made less and less sense to create
the nc by the end of the 1990s
oracle had made little progress they
were still the largest database company
in the world but the nc didn't go
anywhere
and oracle now had a major competitor
called infomix
around the same time though internet
companies were blowing up
as the dotcom bubble picked up steam
larry ellison would cleverly pick up on
this opportunity
and embrace the internet he would offer
oracle's various database and network
products through the internet
in the meantime informatics would fizzle
out by themselves
in 1997 informatics would have their own
earnings scandal
and the ceo phil white would end up in
jail
so oracle's major problems would
unexpectedly be solved overnight
and this allowed oracle to rally
exponentially along with the rest of the
dot-com companies
between 1999 and 2000 oracle stock would
grow from just 6
to 40 but by 2000 they would crash back
down to just ten dollars per share
despite their share price crashing
oracle wasn't a better position
than ever before they had little major
competition
and they had a new growth venue which
was the internet given their strong
position in the market
oracle would go on a shopping spree and
they've been on a shopping spree
ever since if you look through their
list of acquisitions
you'll see that they made 55
acquisitions between 2000 and 2010 alone
one of their most famous slush infamous
acquisition of all time was sun
microsystems
for 7.4 billion dollars which gave
oracle control
over the java programming platform
throughout the 2010s oracle has
basically just started doing the same
thing
they still provide database solutions
and acquire a bunch of companies
but they have expanded the cloud
services as well which has proved to be
quite lucrative
but that still leaves a question how did
oracle make so much money with such few
customers
well the answer is pretty simple their
entire customer base is enterprises
who pay oracle massive amounts of money
every single year
and when i say massive i don't mean
thousands or even tens of thousands per
year
i'm talking hundreds of thousands and
millions per year
when we take a look at the size of their
customers this isn't that surprising
for oracle's enterprise resource
planning cloud or oracle erp
48 of their customers make less than 50
million dollars per year
10 make between 50 million and 1 billion
per year
and 30 to make over one billion dollars
basically every single company and
organization you can think of uses
oracle or has used them
in the past everyone from netflix google
amazon walmart chase mit governments
jetblue delhi ebay you get the point
it's basically
everyone considering this it's not
surprising that oracle is worth 245
billion
today in fact i'm surprised that it's
not worth more given the mass
evaluations of other tech companies
right now oracle only has a p e ratio of
19.31
which is the lowest i've seen in the
tech industry recently
but anyway going back to larry ellison
he stepped down from being oracle ceo in
after 37 years but he still owns 35
of the company today this translates to
about 85 billion dollars
but larry is actually worth 113 billion
today
due to a variety of other investments he
has over a billion in real estate
and he used to have a multi-billion
dollar position in netsuite
aside from this it's also believed that
he has a large position in salesforce
but this has not been confirmed larry
also owns oracle team usa
which is a yacht racing team who have
won several america's cups
however by far his most famous
investment was in december
of 2018 when he bought 3 million shares
of tesla
adjusting for the stock split that's the
same as 15 million shares of tesla
today right after he bought it he
actually got screwed
as tesla crashed 50 in early 2019 but
as we all know tesla has since recovered
and soared to unbelievable heights
larry's taken tesla is now worth over 10
billion dollars
and he's actually a tesla board member
today and
that's the story of how larry ellison
made 113 billion dollars
with less than half a million customers
did you guys know about larry ellison
comment that down below also drop a like
if you're impressed by oracle's massive
background role
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one